what's up guys today we're checking out
the NES classic edition this comes out
November 11th so huge think a Nintendo
for sending news early to check out I'm
super excited even just yesterday my
sister was asking if I had a Super
Nintendo or anything here to play some
classic games and the irony this shows
up today so I kind of can't believe it I
do have a Super Nintendo and a 64 but
neither of them are set up let's open it
up this is my childhood you can use two
controllers another control is sold
separately it's little sweets any oh my
gosh Matthew I'm having flashbacks my
childhood your childhood is only a year
ago you're still a child not interested
I'm definitely gonna have to get a
second controller we've got a power
adapter here Oh smells great
HDMI cable power cord oh my god this is
tiny this is like the size of an NES
game but this is the size of what the
cartridges used to be like can you
believe this
Wow
Oh
[Music]
let's set this thing up I can fit all of
these items in the palm of my hand
incredible here's the problem this cords
really short put that right there I
think this might be a much better setup
upstairs my office but I want to play it
on this huge TV
all right let's power it on definitely
something I should play my desk oh my
gosh this is huge so there's 30 total
games on this little tiny guy we're
playing Mario and then trouble play
something else
Oh do you reset and go back to it I'm
having like flashbacks to my childhood
when like you couldn't save games so I
would tell my mom like you can't touch
this you have to leave it on and the
time like my parents like they always
still to this day shut everything off
before they go to sleep they turn lights
off like unplug everything so for them
leaving this on I know for my dad it
drove him absolutely not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is pretty cool the display
settings to have a CRT filter to make it
look like some of the old-school TVs
with the scan lines the four by three
ratio or pixel perfect got Super Mario
Brothers 2 all dream bug
look at these scan lines it looks like
you guys see it you might just have to
trust me that they're there yes I will
save you I'll save you now so those 30
total games I will put all those games
listed right there let me know what you
guys are most looking forward to and I'm
gonna go out of this video now so see
you guys later bye guess what I found my
iPhone 7 dongle it's been missing for
quite some time
this also just came in today this is a
USB type-c hub it has many different
slots for pretty much everything that
you're going to need here I've got one
of the new MacBook Pros or if you have
one of the MacBook Airs you can power it
with USB see you get two different SD
card slots and to us